even with a run time of more than two
hours eternals is still a dense movie
full of exposition that reshapes the
marvel universe meaningful moments are
dropped in with barely enough time to
breathe before the conversation turns
these are the lines and eternals that
mean more than you realize
when dane whitman finally comes face to
face with icarus the on-again-off-again
ex-boyfriend of cersei things are
understandably a little awkward for some
time he's heard about his girlfriend's
ex and it's never easy to live in the
shadow of someone else especially when
he's got several thousand years on you
how long were you together five thousand
years i guess you can call that long
term dane has been trying hard to get
past cersei's recollections of the pilot
so nicknamed because icarus can fly get
it
now as the information finally begins to
coalesce the line shows that dane is
trying to play it cool he's trying to be
supportive of cersei but is likely
feeling a bit inadequate compared to the
eternal being who can literally fly
after all how would you feel if you
discovered your ex had dated superman
dad that's superman with the cape and
you're shooting laser beams out of your
eyes
dane's question to cersei about why the
eternals sat out the whole thanos thing
poses a question that many mcu fans have
spent time thinking about themselves it
also reflects on a hard-to-grasp reality
about these long-living god-like beings
they're just middle management made by
the celestials to exterminate deviants
that's about it we were instructed not
to interfere
until now
when the eternals were created and
installed on earth all those years ago
they were given orders and they have
followed those orders well humanity has
spent the last several hundred years
thriving both in terms of population and
the development of technologies and
medicine at the beginning of the current
day scenes in the film the deviants have
seemingly been exterminated and the
group have been rewarded with a
well-deserved extended vacation as
details of the emergence are revealed it
should serve as a cause for celebration
among the eternals it signifies a job
well done and although it means the end
of humanity as we know it for the
eternals it's the equivalent of building
a successful branch office and being
promoted to go head up a new region a
few of them are ready to take this pat
on the back and help the bosses with new
development plans this line shows how
cersei begins the film toeing the
company line but eventually comes to
realize she loves her underlings at the
local branch
it's obvious early on that athena is
grappling with some problems and this
line reveals the dark side of that
struggle through flashbacks we learn
that the character is suffering from
something called mad weary which
resembles what we earthlings typically
see in our elderly and would call
dementia thena's eyes glaze over on
occasion indicating an oncoming episode
she'll sometimes forget where she is in
time who she's with and assume they must
be an enemy this can be a very dangerous
thing particularly with someone who has
superpowers and can manifest deadly
weapons at a moment's notice it is
initially believed that thena's mad
weary is the result of being alive for
so long that her memories are becoming
confused as the audience later learns
it's somewhat the opposite fena's
problem isn't that she's forgetting
things it's that she remembers
everything unlike the other eternals her
memory hasn't been effectively wiped
clean with every new deployment all
these memories have become a jumble to
the point where gilgamesh needs to step
in and serve as a caretaker but as it
turns out athena knows enough to
remember the true intentions of the
celestials
find your own purpose and one day when
we see ourselves again i want you to
tell me what you found this line from
ajac drives home the maternal role she
has had in the lives of the eternals for
thousands of years and the mistaken
moment when they believe they've
eradicated the last deviant threat from
earth as prime eternal she's the group's
leader she has the greatest insight into
the celestials helps set the tone and
with these words sends the group on a
long vacation where they are scattered
to the ends of the world kingo becomes a
bollywood star in india cersei moves to
london becomes a teacher and falls in
love ajak finds peace on a ranch in
south dakota fastos settles in the
suburbs of chicago where he also finds
love and starts a family druid lands in
the amazon and uses his powers to
protect or perhaps more accurately
stated zombify a village he comes to
view as a utopia gilgamesh and thena
have settled in australia while makari
seems to have stayed in the spaceship
and caught up on her reading what would
you do if you had several hundred years
of me time to yourself what the eternals
choose to do says as much about them as
any line in the movie it's a shame that
ajax never got to hear their stories
pretty impressive right
possibly the most impactful line from
the film is the one where the eternals
realize that everything dies except for
them because they were never alive it
comes at a key moment when the eternals
essentially have the rug pulled out from
under them for thousands of years they
have been immortal invincible
near-omnipotent celestial beings now
they understand that they're essentially
just worker ants whose hill is about to
be destroyed so they can start anew the
long game of the celestials was known by
a select few of the eternals and each
reacted to it in different ways it
wasn't until the path forward became
clear to cersei that someone became
determined to let it go no further while
possessing the ability to actually put a
stop to it where does the marvel
universe go from here earth now has a
group of super-powered somewhat revealed
heroes soon they might just help the
avengers save the day if only they can
get past their own identity crisis
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one